Now we've got a grammar, and we've got a parser. Let's see what it's good for.
Here's an example of parsing URLs.
Here's an official specification from the W3--the World Wide Web Consortium.
There's a definition on their page. It's not quite in the right format that we use.
But it was very easy to take their format and translate it into our format.
I just sort of went down their rules one-by-one.
Some of them you copy verbatim. Some of them I had to fix up a little bit.
You can see here is the whole specification of the grammar.
It's 40 lines or so. It's fairly involved and verbose.
But it handles URLs.
It was straightforward to go from the specification that they had on their website
to one that could be parsed by the simple parser we built.
Now, I have to say that as I was doing this, I didn't get it all right the first time.
I made a couple of types that made my grammar not work,
and I found this function very useful. I wrote this function to verify a grammar.
What it does is it finds all the tokens that are on the left-hand side and on the right-hand side,
and then it shows them to me.
It shows me the nonterminals, the things that are on the left-hand side.
It shows me the terminals that are the right-hand side but not on the left-hand side.
Those should be the regular expressions. It shows me some suspects. What's a suspect?
That's a something that looks like it's the name and should appear on the left-hand side,
so it's alphanumeric characters, but doesn't.
If they've done that, it's probably because I spelled it wrong in one place
and tried to have the same word used twice and spelled it wrong in one place.
Then there are the orphans.
Those are the things that appear on the left-hand side but don't appear on the right-hand side.
They're useless. They're defined, but they aren't called anywhere.
As I was writing this grammar, I would call this function and say, oops, there's an error.
I fixed it and called the function and say, oops, there's another error. Then I got it right.